[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 21 mars voici le programme de
ce soir après l'adoption définitive de
la réforme des retraites la mobilisation
se poursuit dans les Yvelines
aujourd'hui les étudiants ont bloqué
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines une manifestation à
Élancourt au départ de l'entreprise
Thalès était également organisée par la
CGT à la réuni 200 personnes environ
plusieurs actions sont prévues toute la
semaine on fait le point dans cette
émission un mot de gastronomie également
ce soir dans votre 7 8 7 restaurants
yvelinois ont été distingués par le
guide Michelin cette année parmi eux le
restaurant ruche situé à Gambais il a
été récompensé de l'étoile verte
l'établissement est un modèle en matière
de gastronomie éco-responsable nous est
parti à la rencontre de la chef
américaine si belle idolo elle travaille
avec des producteurs locaux et cultivent
ses propres légumes dans son potager le
portrait de cette adresse pas comme les
autres et enfin direction le château de
Versailles une nouvelle exposition ouvre
ses portes jusqu'au 16 juillet vous
pourrez admirer 9 peintures issues de la
collection personnelle de Louis XIV
c'est la première fois depuis la fin du
17e siècle que les visiteurs pourront
contempler ces tableaux les coulisses
avec notre journaliste Julien Leroy et
puis dans cette partie culture nous
parlerons également de la Villa Savoie
située à Poissy elle lance une nouvelle
expérience en réalité virtuelle pour
découvrir l'architecture moderne de ce
bâtiment d'une manière plus immersive
vous verrez nous parlerons aussi dans
cette émission d'un festival le festival
Jazz à toute heure qui devient le
festival à toute heure en s'ouvrant à
d'autres styles musicaux comme la sole
la pop ou encore le blues pour en parler
avec nous Michel bocage marchand bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur de festival alors
pourquoi cette année vous avez décidé de
vous étendre à d'autres styles musicaux
et ne pas faire que du jazz parce que la
programmation c'est énormément élargi en
fait elle est suivie l'air du temps ou
maintenant on a plutôt tendance à se
constituer des playlists avec des
artistes qu'on apprécie et donc il y a
forcément une diversité donc on a voulu
être dans cet air du temps et avoir une
programmation qui ressemble à une
playlist avec un petit peu tous les
styles de musique qu'on aime et il y en
a beaucoup et donc on parlera un peu
plus en détail de la programmation de ce
festival tout à l'heure avec nous
également plateau Jennifer Suarez Garcia
et Mélanie tevatazan bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir alors vous venez nous parler
d'une association les idéateurs cette
association elle a pour objectif de
promouvoir la création des jeunes
entreprises dans les collèges et les
lycées de la région pourquoi promouvoir
l'entrepreneuriat chez les jeunes
c'est une très bonne question qu'on nous
pose souvent l'entrepreneuriat en fait
tout simplement c'est entreprendre aussi
sa vie entreprendre un projet et une
autre rencontre que nos jeunes ont
besoin en fait d'avoir des devoir créer
en fait quelque chose de leur propre
main de pouvoir aussi de l'entreprise
des différents métiers des entreprises
des immersions et nous on souhaite on
trouve ça en fait indispensable de
commencer à tout âge et donc on est très
fier d'accompagner maintenant 4000
jeunes par an sur toute la région
Île-de-France plus la nouvelle Aquitaine
avec laquelle on commence cette année
donc vraiment je m'entreprise on est à
fond derrière et alors en quelques mots
les idéateurs qu'est-ce que c'est
Mélanie te battazan alors je dirais
c'est qui les idéateurs parce qu'en fait
c'est des jeunes de 13 à 25 ans qui vont
avoir une idée donc les idéateurs et qui
vont passer à l'action et se mettre
vraiment en action de concrétiser leurs
idées on va le voir peut-être un peu
plus tard sur le salon départemental des
Yvelines ils ont sur l'espace de 5 mois
monter un projet
la partie ils sont partis chercher du
financement etc et dans le c'est qui je
dirais aussi c'est les adultes qui les
accompagnent pour qu'ils puissent en
fait concrétiser leurs idées et en fait
je pense que c'est aussi un état
d'esprit les idéateurs c'est vraiment
cette idée de comme ce que disait
Jenifer c'est entreprendre sa vie et
développer des compétences qu'on dirait
douce entre guillemets pour pour les
aider en fait vraiment à monter leur
avenir en fait oui donc on parlera de
ces projets un peu plus en détail tout à
l'heure il y a eu plusieurs prix trois
prix qui ont été remis au salon
départemental des Yvelines on fera le
point tout à l'heure on fera aussi le
point sur les informations du jour à
retenir dans les Yvelines mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
matin la pluie sera bien présente sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 9 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi la pluie devrait continuer
de tomber compter 14 degrés à ou dans et
13 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles
et Rambouillet de fortes rafales de vin
sont aussi annoncés dans les Yvelines en
fin d'après-midi et dans la nuit et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Léa le
pont maintenant sur les informations du
jour dans les Yvelines avec Céline
Charles
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir On commence ces
informations du jour avec Olivier Dubois
le journaliste retenu en otage pendant
presque deux ans il est revenu ce midi
sur le territoire français c'est à la
base aérienne de Vélizy-Villacoublay
dans les Yvelines que le journaliste
Olivier Dubois retenu en otage pendant
711 jours au Sahel atterrissent ce midi
le président Emmanuel Macron est venu
l'accueillir sur les lieux le
journaliste indépendant correspondant de
libération le point ou encore jeune
Afrique avait été enlevé à Gao dans le
nord du Mali où il était venu
interviewer un cadre d'un groupe
djihadiste il a été libéré hier lundi 20
mars on le disait en début de cette
émission les mouvements de contestation
contre la réforme des retraites se
multiplient dans le département oui
malgré l'adoption définitive de la
réforme des retraites par l'Assemblée
nationale après le rejet des deux
motions de sang sur la mobilisation ne
faiblit pas dans les Yvelines ce matin
une manifestation avait lieu à Élancourt
à l'initiative des syndicats CGT et cf
et avec le soutien de l'ensemble du
secteur de la métallurgie du territoire
près de 200 personnes se sont retrouvées
devant l'entreprise Thales plusieurs
employés ont d'ailleurs rejoint le
mouvement le cortège s'est ensuite
dirigé vers Airbus et CRMA écouter tous
les jours il y a des initiatives et nous
on continuera par la grève par les
mobilisations des travailleurs à se
battre pour obtenir le retrait de ce
projet et ce n'est pas qu'une ça plutôt
pi puisque la bien vu avec le CPE que
qu'une loi même votée et là elle n'est
pas votée peut-être non promulgué et
elle peut même être tirée donc on
continuera le combat par la mobilisation
jusqu'au retrait le rejet il concerne
toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles donc il y a un
rejet massif aussi de la part des
salariés de Thalès l'idée c'était de
ramener une manifestation à proximité
des salariés puisque venir sur Paris ou
dans les grandes villes c'est pas
toujours évident même s'il y a des cars
qui sont affréter ils sont très vite
pris et donc là c'était au plus près et
une deuxième manifestation si on aura
lieu au départ de la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines jeudi 23 mars
à 10h et une manifestation au flambeau
au départ de l'hôpital de Rambouillet
prendra prendre place le vendredi 24 à
18h30 et ce mouvement de contestation
impact tout le monde une trentaine
d'étudiants en bloqué plusieurs
bâtiments de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à Guyancourt
des 6 heures ce matin les revendications
sont les mêmes le retrait de la retraite
écoutez cette interview c'est vraiment à
tout le monde d'être dans la rue parce
que cette réforme va nous précariser
d'autant plus parce que il y aura plus
de monde sur le marché du travail et du
coup plus de jeunes au chômage et on
veut vraiment mettre pression à la
présidence de la fac qui n'a pas réagi
lors du dernier blocage qu'on a fait
mercredi dernier et là encore une fois
c'était une vraie surprise pour eux et
en tout cas on sait qu'il y a eu
vraiment beaucoup d'impact on attend
quand même encore une réponse de la
présidence qui ne s'est toujours pas
manifester et qui refuse le dialogue
avec nous
une assemblée générale réunissant une
soixantaine d'étudiants a eu lieu dans
la matinée ils ont voté plusieurs
actions importantes dans les jours à
venir et c'est une contestation présente
aussi dans les raffineries du pays
plusieurs sont à l'arrêt de production
depuis ce week-end à court terme à court
terme les stocks sont suffisants pour
faire face mais des durcissements de
blocage pourraient avoir lieu une
première acquisition à d'ailleurs du
personnel a d'ailleurs été demandé ce
matin par le gouvernement selon l'AFP au
niveau national environ 12% des stations
services de France sont à court
d'essence et de gasoil et 6% totalement
à sec vous pouvez bien sûr retrouver la
situation en temps réel sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran c'est demain
que s'ouvrent les candidatures pour
devenir volontaire aux Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 tout à fait Mathilde 45000
volontaires sont attendus pour
participer aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 accueille
assistance organisation ou encore
transport sont les missions qui pourront
être donnés durant les Jeux les
conditions d'inscription sont simples
avoir 18 ans au 1er janvier 2024 parler
le français et où l'anglais et être
disponible au moins 10 jours le portail
des volontaires ouvre ce mardi 22 mars
et prendra fin en mars en mai prochain
et on termine ces informations du jour
Céline avec du sport du football plus
particulièrement Mathilde dans le
championnat de National inversailles
perd le précieux point dans la course à
la première place sur le terrain du Mans
les joueurs de la cité royale n'ont pas
trouvé la faille et non pas pu faire
mieux que match nul 0 à 0 conséquence au
classement Martigues s'empare de la
place de leader avec un point d'avance
sur Versailles prochain match pour le FC
Versailles ce vendredi sur le terrain de
Cholet merci beaucoup Céline Charles
dans l'actualité également cette
conférence sur l'Ukraine organisée hier
soir par la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines et le Centre Europe Direct de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la thématique de
la soirée l'Ukraine en trois questions
pour rappel le conflit a éclater suite à
l'invasion du pays par la Russie le 24
février 2022 alors que la guerre se
déroule désormais depuis plus d'un an
sur place spécialiste élue journaliste
ont témoigné sur le sujet au cours de
cette table ronde les propos recueillis
par Jessie Willens de nos confrères de
radio sensation tout l'intérêt c'est de
rencontrer des citoyens et d'échanger
avec eux de manière tout à fait
naturelle sur la situation en Ukraine
puisque c'était le thème de ce soir à la
fois sur l'efficacité des sanctions qui
sont adoptées par l'Union européenne sur
l'élargissement à l'Union européenne et
l'intégration de l'Ukraine dans l'UE et
puis le gros sujet de préoccupation la
désinformation et bien nous avons des
commissions qui travaillent sur le sujet
plus particulièrement la commission de
la défense à laquelle j'appartiens et
nous avons aussi des groupes d'amitié
des groupes qui nous permettent de
parler du crâne dans le groupe d'amitié
France Ukraine c'est une guerre une
guerre effectivement il y a des images
extrêmement fortes il y a des cadavres
une guerre c'est moche mais il faut le
raconter ça et il faut pas se priver de
montrer ce qui se passe vraiment
ce n'est pas du sensationnelisme d'aller
filmer des cadavres c'est juste rapporté
la vérité de ce qui se passe
concrètement sur place et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
on en parlait en début d'émission les
idéateurs est une association qui
s'étend sur toute l'Île-de-France et la
nouvelle Aquitaine et elle a pour
objectif de promouvoir l'esprit
d'entreprendre et de faire découvrir le
monde de l'entreprise auprès des jeunes
et le 16 mars plusieurs jeunes
entreprises ont été récompensés au salon
départemental des Yvelines pour en
parler avec nous Jennifer Suarez Garcia
vous êtes responsable du développement
territorial et vous vous occupez des
projets dans le département des Yvelines
et Mélanie Teva atazan vous êtes
responsable de la communication et de
l'événementiel alors trois prix ont été
remis la semaine dernière lors du salon
départemental des Yvelines et notamment
le prix du département pour la création
d'un escape game c'était par des
collégiens de la Mauldre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
donc en effet donc le 16 mars a eu lieu
donc le salon départemental donc dans la
ville de Marly-le-Roi qui est un peu
notre notre lieu un peu fidèle merci
d'être sur la présente pour nous
accueillir et donc le premier prix donc
le salon départemental le premier prix
donc pardon le département exactement le
Grand Prix du département donc qui a été
donné donc au projet donc mollete dans
la ville de meule donc déjà une
collégiens de 3e qui ont compris en fait
un escape game autour de l'harcèlement
scolaire sensibiliser vraiment tous les
jeunes harcèlement scolaire avec des
énigmes vraiment le côté escape game
mais sur un sujet qui est quand même
assez grave et qui touche les jeunes les
collégiens et puis les plus âgés et donc
de travailler
ils ont aussi un groupe en fait de
jeunes qui qui s'occupe de harcèlement
scolaire et donc c'est vraiment chèque
leur qui leur tient beaucoup à cœur et
c'est important pour eux de le mettre de
d'utiliser le jeu pour sensibiliser les
autres jeunes et les adultes et donc ça
a beaucoup plus au jury donc ils ont
gagné le prix le meilleur prix le prix
du département très très heureux très
fier d'eux voilà donc ils vont pouvoir
le tester cette escape game ils l'ont
déjà testé peut-être ils m'ont testé
auprès de leurs collègues collégiens
mais ça commencera le mois prochain tous
les mercredis ils vont pouvoir tester un
petit peu avec un prix assez avantageux
pour un escape game d'accord voilà et
donc il y a eu deux autres prix qui ont
été remis alors pour kit kids c'est le
coup de cœur des jeunes entrepreneurs et
pour splash and boom c'est c'est le coup
de coeur dans c'est l'inverse du jury
c'est pour kitkit et le contraire des
entrepreneurs c'est splash and boom
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler
exactement alors très beau projet plutôt
accès associatif cette fois-ci moins de
commercial avec un sujet qui touche
plutôt avec les parents les parents
isolés qui ont peu les moyens pour
offrir de beaux vêtements à leurs
enfants donc en fait ils récupèrent en
fait tous les vêtements qui n'ont qui ne
sont plus utilisés et donc pour les
offrir assez assez familles isolés ou
monoparentales et à côté un très beau
projet pareil de 3e collégien
sensibilisés
la solidarité pour tous et à côté ils
vont aussi des bougies qui font qui font
eux-mêmes il venait d'où ces collégiens
le collège Louis Lumière et donc le prix
en effet le prix Coup de Coeur donc
splash and boom qui est de la création
en fait de de savon à colorer et donc
fait main fait maison encore une fois
donc à beaucoup plus à nose
entrepreneurs de belles idées de beaux
projets comment est-ce que ça se passe
concrètement comment est-ce que ça se
met en place comment est-ce qu'il
propose leurs idées alors les idées une
grosse étape je rappelle le
brainstorming tous les entrepreneurs
connaissent un long procédé pour trouver
une idée puisqu'on collectif donc il
faut qu'il se mette d'accord également
et donc nous on les a pas vraiment un
peu en donnant plein d'outils plein de
plein de petits outils voilà des de
l'accompagnement aussi collectif
individuel sur comment choisir une idée
également aussi les aspects de
développement durable qui sont très
importants et qui doivent être en
sensibilisés à tout ça et puis aussi ils
sont surtout accompagnés par leurs
professeurs qui est très engagé et
Mobilis et donc ensuite vous vous les
aider à développer leur projet avec un
business plan à trouver peut-être des
investissements comment ça se passe on a
des outils pédagogiques on leur donne et
qu'on vraiment pour les accompagner
c'est leur dès le départ on leur dit
c'est votre projet c'est votre idée nous
on est là pour vous aider vous chapoter
sur sur le Tour et pour rebondir ce que
sur ce que j'ai une faire disait on va
vraiment partir de sur ce qui les agace
au quotidien sur les irritants et
ensuite ensemble ils vont échanger ils
vont prendre des petits post-it on va
aller tout noter ils vont voter ils vont
vraiment partir sur ces aspects là et en
fait on va leur mettre en position aussi
de ben maintenant on a besoin d'argent
parce que pour monter une boîte on a
besoin d'argent et donc il va falloir
aller chercher cet argent et qui on va
contacter en fonction de nos besoins
quel combien ça va coûter etc et on leur
donne vraiment tous les outils pareils
pour faire un business model canvas etc
tous ces outils là on leur fourni et
après c'est vraiment eux qui vont le
prendre se nourrir de ces documents là
et s'adapter en fonction et développer
leur projet leur idée à leur manière et
c'est ça aussi qui est hyper intéressant
et enrichissant pour nous c'est de voir
que comment eux voient le monde et
comment eux vont réfléchir aux
problématiques actuelles que nous nous
avons aussi en tant qu'adulte mais avec
leur regard jeune et hyper frais et
rafraîchissant et donc développer des
idées comme cette idée de escape game
autour de l'harcèlement scolaire pour
sensibiliser sensibiliser pardon les
jeunes et les moins jeunes aussi parce
que nous aussi en passant sur les stands
ils nous happer par leur projet ils
avaient décoré tout les stands vraiment
par leur thématique et donc c'est
vraiment tous ces aspects là qui vont
faire que le projet va évoluer et ça
leur permet quoi assez jeune
l'entrepreneuriat de se révéler de
prendre confiance en eux de découvrir
des compétences des vocations peut-être
tout ça
vous avez raison en effet oui de faire
des compétences par exemple la gestion
de gestion d'une équipe qui n'est pas
simple quand on est en entreprise on
travaille avec des gens le relationnel
c'est également aussi la prise de parole
à l'oral aussi par le pitch le Pitois le
site commercial ça peut être aussi la
créativité on a des jeunes par exemple
qui sont pas scolaires on va dire ce que
ce qu'on appelle scolaire mais qui sont
très bons par exemple pour dessiner pour
designer pour imaginer même aussi pour
gérer les conflits et donc en fait ça
les révèle aussi par rapport déjà à leur
alors collègues leur camarades mais
aussi envers eux-mêmes ce qui prennent
en eux et ils disent ah bah c'est génial
j'ai envie de faire ça c'est ce qui me
plaît je me lance donc c'est un bon
révélateur c'est vraiment un prétexte
pour que si on reprend le jeu de
l'Escape game on joue à un jeu de
l'entrepreneuriat et en fait les jeunes
s'y prennent et vont vraiment développer
des compétences tout autour pour qu'ils
vont leur servir dans la vie
professionnelle mais aussi dans la vie
personnelle parce qu'on parle aussi de
communication non violente pour
apprendre à échanger entre nous sans
blesser forcément les sentiments de
l'autre parce qu'on a tous des émotions
et c'est vrai que quand on passe de du
collège au lycée de la période de
l'adolescence on a tous vécu c'est hyper
compliqué aussi de mettre des mots sur
les sentiments et sur des ressentis etc
on va vraiment se de l'entrepreneuriat
comme un jeu et comme un moyen pour
qu'ils puissent se révéler
au niveau du développement personnel et
aussi professionnel de l'air compétences
et bien merci à vous deux Jennifer
Suarez Garcia et Mélanie tevatazan
d'avoir accepté notre invitation le site
Internet de desiderateurs s'affiche en
bas de votre écran si vous souhaitez
avoir plus de renseignements on va
passer à un tout autre sujet à présent
les fermes de Gally organise un grand
job dating ce samedi 25 mars il aura
lieu au sein du magasin de Saint-Cyr
l'école de 10h à 14h pour en parler avec
nous Bruno ghansel bonsoir alors vous
êtes le responsable de la communication
et de l'événementiel pour l'enseigne à
Saint-Cyr l'école les postes qui seront
à pourvoir quelles sont les domaines qui
sont qui sont à pourvoir une très grande
diversité de postes à pourvoir il y a
plus d'une cinquantaine de postes qui
sont à pourvoir sur les métiers qui sont
au cœur du jardin du paysage et de la
nature et ça à travers une très grande
diversité de le contrat il y a des
postes en CDI il y a des post-ences CDD
on recherche des saisonniers il y a des
stages qui sont proposés donc une très
grande diversité de poste donc 50 postes
c'est c'est énorme c'est habituel aux
femmes de Galy
le groupe FM de Gally et une entreprise
qui compte quelques centaines de
salariés donc c'est une entreprise qui
se développe donc il faut qu'on puisse
pour voir j'allais dire tous les postes
qui se qui se créent et puis les les
gens qui qui partent également il faut
les remplacer donc on a régulièrement
oui pas mal de pas mal de postes à
pouvoir c'est des postes qui peuvent
être très différents sur des métiers du
du paysage donc c'est à dire des métiers
qui visent à embellir les entreprises
aussi bien les jardins d'extérieur que
ramener du végétal au sein de
l'entreprise donc où il y a des postes à
pourvoir en création c'est-à-dire la
réalisation de chantier ou en entretien
ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon de
l'entretien c'est-à-dire des des jardin
qui vont passer pour tailler entretenir
arroser tous les végétaux qu'on a mis en
place
chez nos clients il y a des postes à
pourvoir au sein du magasin donc aussi
bien dans le secteur du végétal où on
recherche des pépinièresistes des
vendeurs de végétaux c'est le printemps
depuis deux jours donc on a enfin le
soleil qui revient et des conditions
propices à remettre les pieds dans son
jardin ou entretenir son balcon sa
terrasse et on va venir vouloir embellir
tous ces espaces là donc on recherche du
monde sur ce secteur là également on a
au sein du magasin des fermes de Gally
un espace de produits du terroir en
circuit court on recherche également des
des salariés pour venir mettre en rayon
conseiller la clientèle vendre vendre
nos produits on va avoir bientôt
l'ouverture de la cueillette
l'accueillette de Gally et donc là on
recherche des postes de saisonniers
également voilà à la production ou bien
également pour faire du Conseil et au
niveau des casques donc effectivement au
niveau des fermes de Galilée il y a
beaucoup de postes pour voir pourquoi
est-ce que vous organisez de grands job
dating c'est un peu inédit c'est la
première fois au sein du magasin que ça
se fait c'est la première fois on doit
ce qu'on a souhaité faire ce samedi
prochain c'est de d'accueillir les gens
qui sont à la recherche d'emploi sur ces
secteurs du jardin du paysage ou de la
nature au sein même du magasin de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent voir
vraiment l'environnement dans lequel ils
vont travailler il y a bien sûr l'équipe
RH des ressources humaines qui sera
présente mais il y aura également des
salariés donc c'est l'occasion de vivre
un petit peu l'expérience en
avant-première de rencontrer de
rencontrer ses futurs collègues donc on
s'est dit que
le fait de pouvoir accueillir des
candidats potentiels in situ sur le
magasin ça peut permettre de vraiment
prendre un petit peu la température et
voir comment est-ce que ça se passe
l'ambiance qui règne donc il va y avoir
des entretiens il faut que les candidats
viennent avec avec un CV une lettre de
motivation qui qui viennent échanger
avec avec les salariés avec l'équipe des
ressources humaines et on va faire ça de
manière très sympathique et essayer de
faire vraiment toucher du doigt les jobs
qu'il y a à se saisir chez nous est-ce
qu'il y a un profil type pour travailler
au ferme de Gally des valeurs peut-être
à avoir il y a des valeurs fortes on est
sur des milieux qui touchent le vivant
le végétal donc il faut avoir une
attirance pour pour le vivant le
vivant c'est pas comme un crayon comme
un portable ou comme une boîte de
conserve on peut pas la laisser sur sur
une étagère et sans s'en occuper donc il
faut avoir de l'attirance pour ce milieu
là et une attirance pour la nature de
être passionné du de son métier on est
vraiment des l'ensemble des salariés de
Noël ils sont des gens souvent très
passionnés et alors comment ça va se
passer concrètement les gens arrivent
avec leur CV et leurs lettres de
motivation mais ils vont être enfin quel
est le le monde des personnes qui vont
pouvoir accueillir les demandeurs
d'emploi Comment comment est-ce qu'ils
vont être accueillis il doit y avoir
grosso modo il va y avoir une dizaine de
personnes en permanence qui seront
présents au sein du magasin
l'objectif c'est d'avoir en fonction de
l'influence du des discussions à One to
One avec avec les candidats et expliquer
présentés précisément les postes qui qui
sont pour voir essayer de voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire matcher
l'attirance d'un candidat avec un poste
à pourvoir échanger avec lui lui
expliquer très concrètement en quoi va
consister ce poste lui faire
éventuellement rencontrer un salarié qui
réalise déjà ses missions là de manière
à ce que le candidat
ne se projette pas que virtuellement
dans le métier mais puisse voir de
manière très concrète et puis vivre
l'environnement dans lequel il va
travailler donc il y aura à la fois des
de l'équipe de des ressources humaines
et également des salariés qui sont en
poste de manière à pouvoir
pas uniquement j'allais dire juger les
candidats d'une manière traditionnelle
sur un CV une lettre de motivation et en
entretien bien évidemment ces étapes là
seront proposés elles sont primordiales
c'est un préalable mais on souhaite qui
est un début de mise en situation et en
tous les cas que le candidat sache où il
met les pieds et se rendre compte de
l'ambiance qui règne au sein des fameux
alors est-ce que les candidats auront
une réponse le jour J ou est-ce qu'il
faudrait qu'ils attendent un petit peu
dans tous les cas on s'engage à faire
une si la réponse a pas lieu le jour J
on s'engage à faire des retours très
rapides et c'est d'autant plus facile
qu'il y aura eu un contact
sur différents aspects et donc ça sera
d'autant plus facile de de juger des
deux côtés d'ailleurs de juger de la
part de l'entreprise
comment est-ce qu'on ressent le candidat
mais également de la part du candidat de
savoir si
ils se sont potentiellement bien dans
cette entreprise dans le magasin
l'esprit de d'entreprise pourra être
ressenti par le candidat et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup l'habitude de voir quand on est
dans des processus classiques de
recrutement en tout cas si vous êtes
intéressé le job dating aura lieu samedi
prochain à la ferme de Gally de
Saint-Cyr-l'École de 10h à 14h 50 postes
sont à pourvoir alors n'oubliez pas
votre CV alors Bruno Gansel ont à
l'approche de Pâques on va parler un
petit peu de la fête des œufs c'est une
fête traditionnelle aux femmes de Gally
cette année les familles auront le droit
encore une fois à la chasse aux œufs
j'imagine bien évidemment il y a pas de
fête de Pâques sans sans chasse aux œufs
c'est une tradition au ferme de Gally
avec le renouveau avec le printemps on
organise cette traditionnelle chasse aux
œufs où il y a des œufs de toutes les
couleurs qui sont
positionnées dans nos pré on a grande
surface de près et donc il y a deux
parcours en fonction de l'âge des
enfants les enfants doivent partir à la
recherche d'une combinaison d'oeufs de
couleurs une fois qu'ils ont leur
combinaison ils vont échanger leur
combinaison d'oeuvre de couleur contre
des des œufs en chocolat donc ça c'est
bien sûr un incontournable de ce
week-end mais il y a plein d'autres
choses il y a aussi des ateliers des
démonstrations de tentes de moutons de
chiens de berger
beaucoup de choses il y a plein
d'ateliers on va avoir des animations
effectivement avec des chiens d'Hergé
voir comment est-ce que une bergère en
l'occurrence fait travailler son son
chien avec un troupeau de mouton la
tombe des moutons puisque c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on quand on ces animaux et
puis plein d'ateliers autour de
plantations des ateliers manuels on va
faire faire des des nids aux enfants
toujours sur le thème sur le thème de
l'oeuvre des démonstrations avec un
tourneur sur bois il y a 1000 activités
à venir faire ce week-end du 8 et 9
avril vous faites toujours autour du
plateau la chasse aux œufs en famille
ça fait un petit moment
pour le chocolat
les enfants bien sûr
en tout cas si ça vous intéresse du coup
la chasse aux œufs c'est à la ferme de
Gally de Saint-Cyr-l'École merci
beaucoup
c'est d'avoir répondu à nos questions la
fête des œufs aura lieu le 8 et le 9
avril de 10h à 17h30 si vous êtes
intéressé vous trouverez plus de
renseignements sur le site internet les
fermes de gally.com alors après les
autres pack et le chocolat on continue
sur notre lancée on va parler de
gastronomie cette restaurant
ivinois ont été distingués par le guide
Michelin cette année parmi eux la ruche
située à Gambais il a été récompensé de
l'étoile verte car l'établissement est
un modèle en matière de gastronomie
éco-responsable la chef américaine si
belle et de l'autre travaille avec des
producteurs locaux et cultivent ses
propres légumes dans son potager le
portrait de cette adresse pas comme les
autres
dans ce restaurant à quelques pas de la
cuisine les navets côtoie le fenouil ils
attendent patiemment d'être récoltés
pour être cuisiné le jour même c'est
notamment grâce à cette philosophie que
la ruche a été distinguée de l'étoile
verte par le guide Michelin l'étoile
verte c'est donner
récompense des personnes qui font
particulièrement attention à
l'environnement circuit court travailler
avec les producteurs qui respectent
l'environnement éventuellement les gens
qui ont un potager comme nous qui
travaillent qui cultivent leur propre
légumes on fait notre carte en fonction
de ce élève actuellement ce qui nous
propose donc par exemple l'éleveurs de
Bova et il va avoir de temps en temps
les avantages mais ça va être une date
par exemple donc on va partager avec
d'autres chefs de la région et
l'obtention de cette reconnaissance du
guide Michelin a été une véritable
surprise pour les deux l'obtention de
l'étoile vert c'est toujours une
distinction qui est une surprise on
s'attend pas surtout ne cherche pas du
tout à voir quoi que ce soit nous on
travaille en procurant nos clients en
fait une expérience ce restaurant situé
à Gambais depuis 2019 est composé d'une
dizaine d'employés ils mettent aussi
bien la main à la pâte en cuisine que
dans le potager de je suis très contente
de cette étoile verte parce que ça a
beaucoup de sens pour moi je voulais un
peu me
décrocher de la gastronomie à la base et
en fait quand j'ai vu cette offre
d'emploi sur un restaurant où il y a un
vrai respect des produits que ce soit
animal ou végétal ça m'a beaucoup plu ce
côté
on essaye vraiment de travailler le
produit jusqu'au bout le côté jardin le
côté tout ça ça me faisait énormément
cette manière de travailler plus
durablement c'est une évidence pour la
chef américaine
engagement c'est pas nouveau pour moi
j'ai grandi à Francisco donc c'est
berceau de
l'écologie et correspondibilité donc
c'est quelque chose que j'ai toujours
connu on s'adapter à la nature en fait
c'est notre potager c'est un potager un
grand travail culture donc il faut vivre
avec la nature et s'adapter à la nature
c'est on s'impose rien donc il y a pas
d'intrants tout est fait avec des
endroits naturels on a par exemple les
écuries et les arafes autour de chez
nous et nous fournissent le fumier par
exemple on peut utiliser ça pour nourrir
notre potager un potager qui s'étend sur
une surface de 2000 m² et qui est doté
d'une serre ici les sont cultivées en
fonction des saisons on a les épinards
des navets on a des fenouils des choux
des brocolis les
betteraves voilà donc même en plein
hiver on arrive à faire des choses
pas en abondance comme on était et on
arrive à faire des légumes vraiment sans
aucun intermédiaire les produits du
potager sont directement travaillés par
la chef qui propose une cuisine créative
et délicate avec des menus dégustation
allant de 3 à 6 services
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde alors comme d'habitude le mardi
vous nous présentez vos informations
insolites dans les Yvelines de quoi
est-ce que vous allez nous parler ce
soir aujourd'hui j'ai trois petits
sujets le premier c'est-à-dire je vais
vous parler d'une épice la nigelle
d'accord c'est exotique aujourd'hui
le thème et le CBD et en troisième
partie une avant-première de d'Artagnan
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye on a hâte
d'entendre tout ça mais ce sera juste
après la partie culture qu'on va ouvrir
à l'instant
[Musique]
et on démarre cette partie culture par
une exposition au château de Versailles
jusqu'au 16 juillet vous pourrez admirer
neuf peintures de la collection du roi
Louis XIV habituellement accroché à 6
mètres de hauteur vous pourrez
contempler ces portraits de prêt pour la
première fois depuis le 17e siècle le
reportage de Julien Leroy
près des œuvres du Roi Soleil 9
peintures issues de la collection
personnelle de Louis XIV sont présentés
au château de Versailles dans
l'exposition chef-d'œuvre de la chambre
du roi provenant de ce lieu central de
la demeure du monarque ces portraits ont
dû être décrochés suite aux travaux en
cours dans l'appartement royal des
tableaux qui ornent à la fois les dessus
de porte ce sont les ovales que nous
voyons ici et dans la partie haute de la
chambre en natique 6 tableaux 6 tableaux
qui proviennent de ces collections qu'il
a acheté dans les années
760 770 des oeuvres inspirées de
l'artiste Caravage mettant en scène peu
de personnages et bouleversant les codes
de la peinture à l'époque une esthétique
sobre et purée contrastant avec
l'ornementation de la chambre du roi et
certainement
il admirait
ses tableaux ces tableaux qui ont tous
un sujet religieux la religion va en
prendre de plus en plus
de place
dans son quotidien et ces tableaux
avaient certainement pour lui une
puissance d'évocation lors de la
création de sa chambre Louis XIV décide
de donner à l'artiste peintre Valentin
de Boulogne une place dominante un des
grands noms du 17e siècle au style
emprunt de gravité et de mélancolie ce
qui est merveilleux dans ce dans ce
tableau c'est les contrastes et les jeux
de textures je dirais entre l'aile qui
est l'aile d'un
oiseau et au contraire les physiques
burinés du sein
habituellement accroché à 6 mètres de
hauteur il est possible d'admirer de
près ces portraits pour la première fois
depuis la fin du 17e siècle l'exposition
chèvre de la chambre du roi se tiendra
au château de Versailles jusqu'au 16
juillet 2023
il s'agit de la 24e édition le festival
Jazz à toute heure revient jusqu'au 15
avril en Vallée de Chevreuse mais avec
un autre nom il devient festival à toute
heure cette année la programmation
s'élargit à d'autres styles musicaux du
blues du reggae de la chanson française
pour en parler avec nous Michel bocage
marchand vous êtes le directeur de ce
festival alors parmi les têtes
d'affiches du festival Nathalie Dessay
Molly Johnson ou encore les Brooklyn
Brooklyn funk essentiel il y a d'autres
artistes à découvrir enfin forcément
vous avez raison de choisir ces trois-là
parce que justement ils sont tombés bâti
de notre nouveau nom festival à toute
heure ne serait-ce que Nathalie Dessay
qui a pas qui était une grande star du
lyrique et qui est passé à la comédie et
à la chanson française avec une petite
touche jazzy quand même puisqu'elle
avait commencé par un hommage à Claude
Nougaro et là elle chante Michel Legrand
donc ça reste dans l'esprit les Brooklyn
funk et Sanchez on est vraiment à la
funky music
donc un style complètement différent du
jazz et puis Molly Johnson c'est de la
pop jazz mais ça reste quand même de la
pop musique alors pour se plonger dans
l'ambiance je vous propose d'éc tout de
suite le teaser du festival ça va vous
donner de bonne humeur vous allez voir
[Musique]
alors Michel bocage marchand vient
d'entendre de nombreux styles musiques
de musique différents c'est ça aussi la
volonté de festival à toute heure de
mélanger les répertoires oui tout à fait
on était au départ un festival
thématique lorsqu'il a été créé en 1999
avec notre parrain qui est toujours là
André saccarelli qui est l'un des
meilleurs batteurs de jazz du monde et
puis petit à petit on a fait rentrer de
la du blues qui est naturellement à
parenté au jazz si je puis dire les
musiques du monde et puis ça c'était
l'argile parce que voilà parce que comme
je disais tout à l'heure on a envie de
faire une espèce de playlist
qui fait que on passe plus facilement de
la pop au jazz à la fin de musique à la
chanson française à chaque fois avec la
volonté de d'aller vers le public avec
des artistes qui sont faciles d'accès
c'est à dire qu'il sait c'est pas une
musique qui est très compliquée au sens
où il faut vraiment la connaître pour
l'apprivoiser ce qui peut être le cas
dans certaines époques du jazz notamment
et donc là non on rentre tout de suite
dans l'univers de l'artiste et des
artistes à sensation immédiate si je
puis dire et ça c'est important pour la
rencontre avec le public et puis vous
avez cité des têtes d'affiches mais on a
aussi toujours à cœur d'avoir des
découvertes dans notre programmation
l'année dernière on était les premiers à
programmer Samara Joy qui vient d'avoir
le grémé Award de la meilleure chanteuse
devant toutes les chanteuses quelle
chanteuse de jazz pour le coup mais
devant les chanteuses de pop et de et de
variétés donc on en est fier on avait
découvert aussi un avant-première
kimberose Ayo donc voilà
ils ont un nom voilà un petit peu
shooting qui s'appelle La Muse Gueule
voilà c'est un groupe qui vient de la
région Rhône-Alpes et on est dans
l'électro swing donc quelque chose de
très dansant très jeune pour le coup
dans l'esprit ce que fait Caravan Palace
par exemple donc ça je pense que ça va
être une découverte forte
dans un autre style Cobi qui est un
chanteur à song Walter américain
donc guitare voix qui est un style qu'on
voit qui commence à revenir mais qu'on
revoit c'est quelqu'un qui a forte
notoriété aux États-Unis mais qui est
pas encore bien connu en France donc là
on est dans un autre registre des
folkingers à lanilion ou de ces époques
là mais moderne et puis dans les
originalités aussi on aura les swing
vandales ce qui proposent un bal Lindy
Hop donc c'est un vrai balle le linkeup
c'est la danse qui est sortie des
ghettos noirs dans les années 30 donc au
départ qui était très lié à la musique
swing et c'est un peu quand ça se danse
à deux ça ressemble au rock n' roll en
fait et ça se lance collectivement façon
Madison donc là nous avons des
animateurs de danse qui proposeront une
initiation aux danses et qui feront
aussi des démonstrations danse pendant
le concert des danseurs autour de la
table ça vous intéresse
il y a beaucoup de styles
on va s'entraîner
et vous Véronique pourquoi pas mais oui
pourquoi pas
alors tout à l'heure vous parlez du
parrain du festival André tchecarelli je
sais pas si je le prononce correctement
il sera donc également sur scène avec le
pianiste Jean-Pierre como et le crooner
italien Walter Richie ils joueront leur
spectacle my little Italie alors
Jean-Pierre como c'est l'un des grands
pianistes de jazz français qui a ses
propres créations et puis c'est associé
avec André sekarellic et une légende
dans la batterie mondiale voilà et des
il a joué avec les plus grands jazzman
mais aussi les plus grands de la pop
musique moi je cite toujours il était à
la fois batteur de Michel Jonasz le
batteur de Starmania à la création de
Starmania et de tidat Turner donc vous
voyez que voilà pour être pendant 15 ans
le batteur de Didier Bridgewater donc le
jazz et sa vraie passion Music et donc
là il joue avec Jean-Pierre como que les
jazzman Français connaissent vraiment
bien qui est un très très grand pianiste
et ils vont faire découvrir André
Ceccarelli et quelqu'un qui aime bien
faire découvrir de nouveaux artistes
tout au long des années du festival il y
a toujours eu souvent à cœur d'apporter
de faire venir un nouvel artiste et
Walter Richie qui est moins connu en
France qui est un krunner
à la fois la Sinatra pour être crooner
mais avec je dirais l'humour italien
donc ça fait quelque chose de tout à
fait original
rendez-vous dans la vallée de vous
attendez combien de personnes là cette
année alors on est un petit festival au
niveau nombre évidemment on n'est pas
comparable à un jazz in Marcillac ou à
Vienne notre capacité d'accueil maximum
c'est 3200 personnes mais sur 14
concerts qui se déroulent sur 8 communes
différentes
particularité c'est qu'on est en tournée
on a trois camions voilà comme les
artistes en tournée pour amener dans des
lieux qui sont pas habituellement des
lieux de concert toute la technique le
sont la lumière et puis aussi la
particularité de certains concerts qui
sont bien fléchés sur notre site qui
sont des concerts en version club c'est
à dire qu'on amène une ambiance club
comme il y avait dans les clubs de jazz
avec des tables et puis une restauration
légère on peut déguster une plancha voir
un coup évidemment si on le souhaite et
avec une grande proximité avec les
artistes donc ça c'est très convivial et
bien merci beaucoup
été laissé le festival à toute heure se
tient jusqu'au 15 avril en Valais de
Chevreuse au total 14 concerts avec 63
artistes vous trouverez tous les
renseignements sur le site internet qui
s'affiche sur votre écran direction
Poissy à présent à la Villa Savoie
remonter le temps est désormais possible
depuis le mois de février le monument
propose une expérience immersive de
réalité virtuelle elle retrace la
construction de cette maison façonnée
par le célèbre architecte Le Corbusier
le reportage de Régine ralech
des images que nous avions 10 minutes
d'expériences immersive au sein de la
Villa Savoie c'est ce que viennent de
tester ces personnes à l'aide d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle les
visiteurs ont pu remonter à l'époque des
années 30 et comprendre la genèse de la
Villa Savoie c'est pour nous vraiment la
possibilité de proposer aux visiteurs
une expérience complémentaire de de sa
visite à la villa et grâce à la réalité
virtuelle de lui donner à voir et à
comprendre et l'histoire de la Villa
Savoie parce qu'on remonte le temps et
puis également les principes
d'architecture du Corbusier cette visite
est le fruit d'un travail de plus de 18
mois réalisé en collaboration avec le
studio lucide realities les visiteurs
peuvent observer l'évolution du site
grâce à des archives de la Fondation Le
Corbusier et entendre les échanges entre
Eugénie Savoie et l'architecte
une visite traditionnelle qu'on peut
faire avec un un audioguide ou même en
visite libre donc oui très très
intéressant ce qui est très
impressionnant c'est de voir le terrain
avant avec une vue absolument splendide
de voir aussi des aspects de
construction de plans l'expérience VR
s'adresse à tous la visite peut
également se faire en anglais et en
public beaucoup plus varié qui vient à
la Villa Savoie maintenant grâce à cette
expérience qui ne sont pas forcément des
fanas d'architecture ou de Le Corbusier
mais qui vont être attirés par cet
aspect virtuel et très moderne la visite
est au prix de 4 roues et est ouverte
tous les week-ends sur réservation
ça vous donne envie de tester autour du
plateau l'expérience de réalité
virtuelle dans cette ville à Savoie
alors oui clairement j'aime bien tout ce
qui est découverte et vivre en fait
réellement un petit peu ce qui se passe
et donc là on est vraiment en immersion
s'imaginer comment ça se passait à
l'époque ça c'est vraiment je pense que
déjà on imaginant on peut on peut
voyager un peu mais là c'est vraiment
être sur place sans vraiment y être donc
ça peut être une expérience assez
chouette je trouve tout à fait
amusant de le retrouver dans un casque
de réalité virtuelle je trouve que c'est
une très bonne idée
en tout cas vous pourrez tester du coup
cette expérience de réalité virtuelle à
la Villa Savoie dans les prochains jours
dans les prochains mois allez c'est
l'heure maintenant de passer aux
informations insolites de Véronique
alors ce soir on commence vos infos
insolites par un salon de thé pas comme
les autres et c'est le cas de le dire
incroyable j'ai quand même pas moi-même
j'ai eu du mal à croire quand j'ai vu ça
alors en fait il s'agit d'Arthur dolmer
et de Jean-Emmanuel Thomas qui était qui
travaillait comme cuisinier au Royal
Monceau à Paris qui était amis et qui en
ont eu un petit peu marées qui ont
décidé de se lancer et ils ont vu que le
marché du CBD fonctionnait très bien ils
sont dit pourquoi pas en vendre et
pourquoi pas surtout faire un salon de
thé non ce serait le thème principal
donc finalement à Versailles tout près
faire ça il y a de plus en plus exotique
c'est pas compliqué je vous avais parlé
du japonais à la street food daysuko
d'accord ils sont à 3 mètres on a le
Japon et on a le CBD juste à côté donc
c'est un salon de thé vous venez vous
pouvez vous serez selon vos goûts ils
ont été assez rares avec ou sans CBD des
infusions avec ou sans CBD des des
pâtisseries avec son CBD le plutôt avec
je crois alors le CBD faut pas avoir
peur c'est juste interdit au moins de 18
ans et
ils vendent bien sûr aussi tous les
produits qu'on peut consommer chez soi
donc soit en huile soit en fleur soit en
résine et ce qui est vraiment
sympathique c'est qu'Arthur de mer et
j'emmène Thomas sont des êtres
absolument adorables qui vous explique
tout selon vos besoins parce que vous
savez comme moi que ces BD ça peut quand
même aider à combattre certaines
douleurs articulaires musculaires oui le
CBD quand même le préciser c'est un
dérivé du cannabis mais ce n'est pas de
la drogue voilà c'est légal c'est
interdit au moins de 18 ans en France et
du coup vous n'avez pas le côté addictif
et au floraison de la drogue c'est
vraiment apaisant et c'est ça peut être
aussi dans la cuisine enfin comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure et ça peut
aider à s'endormir enfin donc si vous
êtes un peu stressé vous faites votre
marché à Versailles après vous allez
faire une grande théière de CDD ça va
vous coulisser de faire une bonne sieste
voilà par exemple voilà un endroit
incroyablement sympathique insolite
insolite pour le mois oui à mon avis oui
et ça marche très bien ils ont des
clients de 30 à 70 ans et plus voilà
alors pour votre deuxième information on
reste à peu près dans le même thème mais
oui puisqu'on passe maintenant à
l'utilisation par un chef d'un produit
pharmaceutique est-ce que c'est bien ça
c'est la nigelle exactement
vous en avez déjà parlé dans le Sept à
Huit c'est à monsieur qui a travaillé
dans des grands groupes qui est
énormément voyagé au Moyen-Orient
notamment il s'appelle Olivier Olivier
Olivier decaze voilà il s'est associé
avec une pharmacien et il a eu envie de
de proposer cette ni gel cette épice
incroyable cette épice c'est pas
compliqué elle guérit de tout sauf de la
mort Mathilde c'est normal
il faut qu'elle soit très bonne donc il
a fait pas mal d'études à sa clef
justement avec cette pharmacien et il la
propose sur un site qui s'appelle OFFICE
DU MONDE bientôt ça sera aussi dans des
pharmacies qui sont en train de
démarcher et donc fais attention à avoir
des produits de bonne qualité et donc ça
vous aide à combattre des problèmes de
peau du cuir chevelu ça ça fait quoi
d'autre
chose c'est que c'est anti-inflammatoire
voilà et donc le chef yvelinois maudit
Sakho on utilise dans dans sa cuisine
bravo alors c'est ça qui m'a fait tilter
c'est quand j'ai vu mon petit Versailles
plus chéri là le mensuel versaillais je
vois donc l'interview de cette Olivier
decaze et au final on voit que votre
chef chéri à vous parce qu'il est
souvent dans les astuces du Cher qui
s'appelle Saco maudit et bien on utilise
dans sa cuisine sous forme d'huile donc
comment est-ce qu'il fait enfin vous
voulez je vous dise je vais vous dire
par exemple là
qui fait des bouchées de rouleau
d'avocats farcis au Tartare de thon
agrémenté assaisonné à l'huile de
nigelle voilà tout simplement il a
d'autres secrets qui vous révélera à
l'occasion voilà on espère on verra
c'est sûr c'est sûr alors on termine vos
informations insolites par une
avant-première nous avons première pour
changer parce qu'on adore le cinéma et
c'est une avant-première qui va avoir
lieu
un lundi le lundi 27 mars à 20h et où à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est un film qui s'appelle
Les trois mousquetaires deux points
d'Artagnan en fait c'est un diptyque
vous avez celui-ci qui va sortir et
après il y aura les trois mousquetaires
deux points midi bon on va rester sur
celui-là pour commencer et en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'Alexandre
Dumas père a écrit ce roman de cap et
d'épée à Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà il
a été aussi commandant non pardon il a
dirigé le commandement de la garde
nationale de Saint-Germain-en-Laye ainsi
son théâtre donc effectivement vu qu'il
y a qu'une seule avant première dans les
Yvelines évidemment il fallait la faire
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà alors ce
film il est réalisé par un metteur un
réalisateur n'importe quoi qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle Martin bourbouleau
d'accord d'accord
on acteur vous avez Françoise civil qui
joue d'Artagnan Vincent Cassel qui joue
je ne sais plus enfin un autre des des
beaux casting en tout cas là
il y a la bande-annonce qui s'affiche en
même temps
Duris c'est Aramis je m'en souviens
parce que ça rime et puis au marma il
dit qu'il a dû prendre 10 kg le pauvre
pour avoir l'air plus lourd évidemment
c'est le but du jeu la vraie sortie
officielle c'est le 5 avril vous avez
Eva Green et c'est ce film a été écrit
par souvenez-vous Alexandre de la
Patelière et Mathieu Delaporte les
auteurs du prénom
donne envie d'aller le voir j'ai
l'impression qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié
de dire d'autre sur cette
j'espère et intérêt le casting donne
envie d'y aller déjà
bon bah c'est bon je crois que j'ai tout
dit j'ai sur mon billet des trucs mais
tant pis donc ce sera aussi au cinéma le
27 mars
lundi 27 20h avec l'équipe du film un
super je crois qu'on a tout dit merci
Mathilde merci beaucoup Véronique pour
ces informations on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant je vous propose de
jeter un dernier coup d'oeil à la météo
de demain
matin la pluie sera bien présente sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures il fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 9 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi la pluie devrait continuer
de tomber malheureusement compter 14
degrés à Houdan et 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Rambouillet de forterafales de vin sont
aussi annoncés dans les Yvelines enfin
d'après-midi et dans la nuit et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]